well kitten jenny frost
joins us out good to see you this
morning look this has been
a long time coming you knew the demand
was there for the from the fans to
to get these lyrics changed why did you
finally decide to do it
you know the girls have been um singing
this song for a couple of years now and
i
was living over the beta and wasn't
working with the girls and then they
called me on monday and said listen
this is really going off would you come
over and get involved and
do it for the lads and i was like yeah
i'm there so an hour later i was in a
recording studio in ibiza and then the
day after on tuesday i was on a flight
on the way over here so it's been quite
whirlwind
i mean it's it's brilliant that you know
you've been
otherwise the fans have been singing it
for a good while the fact that you
managed to get this done and released
and it was such a surprise to everyone
that you've finally done
it it's a great crowd pleaser you know
what it's just after especially after
the past
16 months that we've all had it's just
so lovely to be part of something so
positive
and you know a song from a girl band
that's got all these
testosterone-charged
men singing it from the terraces it's
just magical it's really
wonderful to be part of and you know i'm
here in the look in london now with my
kids
and they've never already experienced
things like this they've all lived their
whole life in ibiza so
you know they're here walking around and
people are singing the song and it's
just
it's really exciting um i mean look
you must be a football fan in all of
this you must be
i mean to do all this you must be really
behind the team
yeah i'm a huge football fan my dad
didn't have any sons and i was the
youngest so i got dragged to anfield
often um
so i was yeah following the team and
very passionate about it so it's just
it's wonderful it's so honestly i'm so
thrilled to be part of it
it's such a big day tomorrow i mean it's
a historic day
win or lose for england if you hear that
being you know as you're watching it on
tv
and you hear that being song from from
the terraces
that's that's gonna be amazing isn't it
it's i mean it's crazy just it's it
gives me goose pimples every time i get
videos sent to me and stuff so i think
tomorrow is going to be it's going to go
down in history for all the right
reasons
i'm very positive about that so um
i've just i can't wait to say i can't
wait to see us win and we're going to
[Laughter]
what's that what did you know where you
um i mean though this came out on the
6th still what's happening in terms of
streaming or charting or how popular
it's being i think we were released on
tuesday
um i was in the airport in ibiza they
released on tuesday when i got off the
plane
it was i was getting messages left right
and center and they were saying it's
going up the charts i think we're at
number four
at the moment um and um i mean it's
quite male dominated charts
with the football songs so it's quite
it's just good that one number four
are very happy with that it's not bad to
go from zero to number four on the chart
so
by the time you've got off the plane no
it's not it's 20 years later
but the girls and i were the girls and i
were laughing about it because we went
straight to a performance at the peter
crouch show which was great fun
but we've not performed together for
like over 10 years or something
and we didn't even rehearse we just got
on stage and we kind of looked at each
other and we're like
maybe we should have rehearsed we've not
done this for a really long time but it
was just
like no time had passed at all so it was
fun yeah so
it's like some things you just never
lose jenny really good to talk to you
this morning
thank you so much